glad Bible is trying to kill me we
shouldn't be consuming these things oh
my
goodness
[Music]
ew hey guys it's Madison Beer and this
is snack Wars the UK versus the US for
lad Bible okay
oo okay there's like a rogue Hershey
Kiss in the Box I don't know if that's
meant for that Colin the caterpillar I
I'm going to like hope and assume this
is meant to eat in like a party setting
but if someone had this at a party I
would be
confused I also just think like the
shape and the size of it is questionable
in many ways like this isn't this
doesn't look good to me this doesn't
look like something I want to eat if
this was at my birthday party when I was
a kid I would have just made like
endless jokes and made fun of everyone
who ate it okay well I'm also apparently
like not able to cut through things as
an adult oh it's like a cake yeah I have
a
little I don't know if I've ever even
like really eaten a chunky aren they
lost for like 50 years I've also heard
that rumor don't know if it's true but
if it is that's scary they would survive
the apocalypse I can't open anything
what's wrong with me like no I'm an
adult let's break it
open like it's just it's like it's not
great let
no but also
no honestly we all will eat that col
like the minute like yeah we love it
this is like a thing you all are aware
of any bir all right well I'm going to
have to vote Twinkie on this one cuz
Colin is scaring me
[Music]
okay okay I really don't like this like
I feel actually a little queasy looking
at
it this looks like like
duster like literally
um oh no it's not
working I don't know how to do it did I
did I break it I think maybe I should do
it on a plate oh there it
is well we'll get to you in a second
first we'll eat some cheeses
cheets are
great cheit
are this is a different flavor these
have something kind of good going on
which I don't know if these are like a
British cheese it no this is American
you don't have chees no got
it well I do like the flavor that you
picked out for me today what do we have
going on over here this is a nice frish
Stilton is blue cheese I love a cracker
of any kind this cheese is not one that
I would usually um gravitate
[Laughter]
towards thank you
wow what an experience that
is what's going on so I hate blue cheese
and like blue crumble if there's like a
salad and it has get it off don't give
it to me if there's like wings and it's
ranch or blue cheese it's always Ranch
like I'm not a blue cheese person it
just is like to moldy to me like that's
what I think of lad Bible is trying to
kill me
everybody this is equally as
un America oh my God yay this is
congealed like what the how it's been 5
minutes we shouldn't be consuming these
things these shouldn't be processed this
is
hard oh my God
oh my
goodness
ew I'm just freaked out that it got like
that oh my goodness it's like a string
you know what America are you listening
we need to be eating things that are
more edible these are things are not
edible for us this looks like duster and
it hardened within 3 minutes of being on
a plate we should not eat that okay but
America's still winning this one yeah
mhm y
yes
wow okay sorry about that it's okay just
just didn't I didn't want to okay I'm
assuming this is us yes this is
UK N Brew is that how we say it is iron
Brew iron there's no o no it's like the
national drink of Scotland so well okay
I guess I should try this this is like a
science experiment it's is there ice
cream in this too yeah oh my goodness
I'm in the UK for like 2 days and I'm
like is there ice cream in this
[Music]
too yeah there's like not much to
complain about
there I've had this heavy it comes in an
orange bottle that's clear right
sometimes in the gas stations and stuff
I've had this and I don't like
it in this war I'm going to have to pick
our very neatly done
us oh my goodness this is exciting oh so
yeah this is where the British start to
lose me because I well there's things
about this that I can get down with and
I'm going to try it because you know
what life is
short this is like a English breakfast
right okay okay sometimes they' serve it
with like black pudding which is like
Cano blood with a pig well maybe I'll
get that on the side good think just
because I have had this and I'm used to
it and I know what we're getting
into before I even try this I'm going to
give this point to the UK because this
is this is good and I'm pleasantly
surprised and I've always wanted to try
this but I would never do it on my own
like okay you
know
well they knew what they were doing when
they made this they really did for like
a British audience can you try and
explain what Lucky Charms are yes
happily I will so how I would explain it
they sweet
little
puffed cereal things which what is
cereal I don't even know cereal with
little rainbow marshmallows nice
nutritious breakfast nice yeah super lot
of
protein oh my God I like there's not
even nutrition facts on this because
like there's none magnesium
and phosphorus those things don't sound
good basically like battery acid but
it's delicious and we Americans love it
I'm giving this to the UK though cuz I
like
that oh these are America oh yeah jelly
beans
High um this is going to be like a big
tossup for the UK because I hate jelly
beans like I'm not a jelly bean fan at
all I'll try one I don't like these I
already know I don't like these
I don't want to say mid cuz I don't want
to be like showing my age but like
mid actually below mid like these are
bad I really don't like them so what I
was going to say is growing up there
were like prank jelly bean packages and
it was like some taste like vomit some
tastes like popcorn what are you going
to get that I think did something like
hardwired my brain into not liking them
what is this consistency it's like
almost gum it's not quite get out of
here anyway this tastes like Play-Doh
and don't ask me how I know what
Play-Doh tastes like cuz unfortunately I
do these win these are just better what
what do those ones say this one has a
hard Emoji or just hard eyes maybe it's
not no these are emojis oh boring we
live in a society yeah oh this one says
lucky lips on it oh okay the US one oh y
okay yeah like
[Music]
does anyone want to
meditate
[Music]
yeah oh
no I've never had McDonald's before in
my whole life and I can't have this